hi my name is Danny tone and I'm a
screenwriter this is my submission for
film courage I have been writing for
about eight years I started as a
performer my degrees actually in Opera
and I learned everything I know about
story structuring from studying opera
and I still love it and I started out
writing content to is a vehicle for
myself and then I just fell in love with
it I fell in love with it like a 13 year
old at a One Direction concert and you
know it's been a passionate love affair
ever since my current project wisdom
which is a modernized adaptation of a
Jane Austen novel called persuasion I
have been working on it for I outlined
in about five years ago and I started
working on the script writing at about
three years ago I picked it up because
um my father had just been diagnosed
with cancer and we knew he was not going
to win this battle and I was very close
to my father and so persuasion which is
one of my favorites I've read it like a
million times is a book about a woman
you know learning to stand on her own
two feet and love herself and you know
as she you know embrace herself as she
is and you know not care about what
anybody else thinks of her which I mean
one it is a universal journey which is
why I wanted to tackle in the first
place but at the point at which i was
writing the script that was also what I
was going through learning to a you know
knowing I was going to have to adjust to
life without my dad um and so you know
Anne's journey you know working through
ins journey is how I worked through mine
and why haven't I quit I haven't quit
because I haven't given myself the
option of quitting um is it's been a few
years you know I had early interests
then I had it starts to come together
and fall apart and I started you know
and then I had a good year where I was
just dragging it forward by myself and
now I'm in early development with a
production company um more negotiations
on that and I'm very very excited about
it and I'm glad I held out for the right
situation and but I never gave myself
the option of quitting
my goal with it I wanted the actual
release and I had two things that I
wanted from this from I wanted to happen
with this film I want a female director
and I want gender equality on that set
and I wrote it with an inclusive cast
I'm very very very passionate about
trying to effect positive change as far
as inclusion goes in the media in
content and I want my inclusive cast and
I you know so I want that film up on a
screen and I want it to do well because
there's a whole tidal wave right now of
inclusive projects that are pushing back
against the myth that you know projects
created by women and crop projects with
inclusive casts don't make money and I
want to be part of the tidal wave that
pushes back against because it's a myth
and let's see I also not see one lesson
is a screenwriter well I'll tell you um
if you want something done learn how to
do what you need to do to do it yourself
is I've had a tremendous amount of
support from women women in film the
whole time but boy once I was like I
guess I could learn to produce and you
know make it myself I mean the level I
can't overstate the level you know how
much they were like great will help will
help you and they and and they they have
i've gotten so much support and you know
even though i've been learning producing
on a steep learning curve I at first you
know I was like oh god oh my god do I
you know now I love it and now I want to
learn to direct which I would have had
the courage to do you know if I hadn't
of stepped up and then you know put my
big girl panties on and been like we are
gonna learn to do this so what I would
say you know big lesson has been you
know if you want something done do it
you know do it do it definitely do it
stand your grant you know if you want
you know stand your ground and let's see
so when do i right when don't i right I
went don't i right I you know if the
juices are flowing then I want to sit
down I want to get it out and you know
later I'll go look and see you know if
there's any good stuff in there and you
know it's like painting for gold it's
it's fun it's awesome I'll up the whole
process my screenwriting goals
are pretty much the same as my goals for
this project I want to create projects
that do not have opportunity gaps
consistently I you know I want to you
know tell people stories tell everyone's
stories you know give a lot of
prospective perspectives on the screen
you know help you know use use film and
television and media as a is a tool
to help create empathy and you know just
being include you know being inclusive
in the perspectives that you write you
know that you know whose stories you
tell and who you cast that's that's my
goal that's what I want to do is I want
to is I got here and I am was a girl
scout for six years and I want to leave
the campfire campsite better than I
found it um that's a big goal for me is
I want to keep creating content that is
inclusive and you know that people
connect to and you know helps them feel
less aina help them feel less alone
that's you know that was always so big
for me growing up I was a you know as a
short fat kid with glasses and a smart
mouth you know public school experience
was not full of positive reinforcement
and you know loving support and it was a
lonely kid who read a lot and consumed a
lot of content you know film and TV and
I you know I want I want to pay it
forward and create content that helps
other people feel less alone and feel
more comforted and feel more you know
yeah less alone and tell a story about
my screen writing career no problem last
year I was brought in by a friend of
mine to do a rewrite on an action film
that was in development and they would
they were looking to have like you know
plot strengthening you know character
creation you know character
strengthening and I was like well
actually it's not really my job I've
never written it I don't know if I'm
gonna be any good at it but you know
it's you so of course I'll take a look
and I didn't get the job um the meeting
was actually kind of a horror show but
you know somewhere in the middle of it I
fell in love with action and I was like
oh this is just like telling every other
story and now one of my goals is to
figure out a female-driven action
pole what's our die hard what's our
mission impossible you know it's that
and so you know that's that's me that's
that's that's me in a nutshell um so
thank you for thank you for listening
thank you for taking the time to watch
this and take good care